[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à Porto Rico en transformant un cratère
naturel en un miroir concave géant les
techniciens américains sont en train de
réaliser un Radi télescope qui sera avec
celui de nany en France le plus grand du
monde suspendu à la verticale du centre
de la cuvette un radar recevra les ondes
reflété et concentré par ce miroir de
330 m de diamètre il convient de
remarquer que le montage du radar fixé
par des câbles au pic du voisinage
au-dessus du vide représente un joli
travail
acrobatique c'est peut-être ici que l'on
enregistrera demain les messages émis
par des galaxies inconnues distinctes de
millions d'années lumières de notre
monde
[Musique]
la locomotive à vapeur qui entraîna les
trains pendant 100 ans et qui fut la
vedette d'un des tout premiers films de
cinéma n'est plus loin de la retraite le
progrès sans cesse plus exigeant lui a
donné une progéniture qui ne lui
ressemble guère parallèlement à
laattacction électrique une autre
branche s'est développé laattraction
diesel ce furent d'abord les petits des
800 chevaux qui se chargèrent des taches
obscur des manœuvres de gare et puis là
où l'électrification n'était pas
rentable des diesels plus puissants se
sont lancés sur les grandes lignes des
chemin de fer français des diesels de
1400 chevaux apparurent puis des 2000 et
des 2600 chevaux et ce n'est pas fini
c'est ainsi que dans les ateliers est en
train de naître celui qui sera le géant
de la série un 4000
chevaux les chemins de fer y perdront
définitivement dans moins de 10 ans leur
panage de fumée mais au profit de la
puissance du confort et de la
[Musique]
vitesse dans le le domaine de
l'automobile une voiture de série prise
au hasard la voiture de monsieur tout
leemonde a battu le record du monde des
300000 km record soumis à l'approbation
de la Fédération Internationale
automobile c'est cette distance
respectable qu'à la moyenne de 106 km/h
une Ford tonus 12 m a bouclé en 117
jours sous contrôle officiel sur le
circuit de miramars six pilotes se sont
relayés toutes les 3 He au volant de
cette voiture qui avec une charge
équivalente au poids de 5 passagers a
roulé par tous les temps de jours comme
de
[Musique]
nuit cette for de tonus 12 m ne devait
être arrêté qu'au bout de 357000 km la
distance de la Terre à la Lune belle
démonstration d'endurance pour une
voiture de
[Musique]
série décembre nous promet un de ces
jours fatidiques auquel pour des raisons
mystérieuses s'attache un potiel de
chance exceptionnelle un vendredi 13 un
jour à ne pas rater un jour qu'il
importe de mettre à profit pour faire
une démarche capitale une demande en
mariage par exemple et à une bonne
[Musique]
adresse jour unique pour tenter la
traversée de la place de la Concorde aux
heur de
pointe jour idéal pour prendre un billet
de la tranche spéciale de la Loterie
nationale avec toutes les chances de son
côté
jour ou jamais où l'on peut s'attendre à
un avis de remboursement du percepteur
et qui n'a pas ses projets pour le
vendredi
13 par Monsieur de spécial le vendredi
13 le vendredi 13 je pense déjà aux
embarras de la circulation pour rentrer
en banlieu merci et vous monsieur que
faitesvous le vendredi 13 je pense à mon
weekend m je prendsill laterie nationale
merci et vous monsieur que faitesv
vendred poiss du poisson et vous patron
que faites-vous de le vendredi 13 ETV le
14 je touche le
[Musique]
gagne ce n'est pas la première fois que
les jolies skilleuses empreintent la
casquette mais c'est bien la première
fois depuis 25 ans que le fuseau
rencontre un adversaire le niqueur
agrémenté bien entendu de tous les bas à
dessin ou sans dessin imaginable c'est
ainsi que Jacques Marot conçoit la
skieuse de l'hiver
6364 celle que nous allons voir bientôt
à Courchevel ou à
[Musique]
meuget toutes les fantaisies sont
permises dans cette forme nouvelle qui
si ell ront délibérément avec la
tradition ne manque ni de style ni
d'élégance devant cette offensive le
fuseau résiste mais transformé amélioré
diraiit même certains le fuseau est
devenu collant et Henry ours à la pointe
de cette formule a conçu toute sa
collection dans ce style les anorques
ont droit à toutes les fantaisies
dessins couleurs et
[Musique]
fourrures enfin pour le soir on n'ose
pas dire le ski du soir voici la
dernière idée tunique en lamé et collant
de soie original à faire pâir le Mont
[Musique]
Blanc un nouveau visage entre à la
maison blanche le président Lindon
Johnson entouré de sa famille sa femme l
Johnson et ses deux filles Linda burn et
Lucy BES seront désormais les autres du
palais qui depuis l'année 1800 abrite le
président des États-Unis cet homme hier
presque inconnu fut le collaborateur de
Truman après avoir été guidé par
rosevelt pour ses premiers pas dans la
politique
[Applaudissements]
américaine la Convention démocrate de
1960 lui préféra Kennedy mais c'est
ensemble qu'il menèrent la campagne qui
devit les porter au
pouvoir vice-président on commença à
voir apparaître sa longue silhouette qui
portait à travers le monde la voix de la
politique
kennéiste c'est ainsi qu'on le vit à
Berlin au lendemain de l'édification du
mur de séparation bâti par le
gouvernement de POV déclaré que les
États-Unis n'abandonnerai jamais
[Musique]
Berlin c'est ainsi qu'on le vite en
Turquie accueilli par le président
toujours et partout acclamé par des fou
enthousiastes qui saluaient en lui la
puissance et l'amitié de la
[Musique]
mairie aujourd'hui Lyon Johnson est
devenu président c'est en cette qualité
qu'il a reçu après le drame de Dallas
Philippe d'Édimbourg et le de krutchov
anastas
[Musique]
mikyam c'est en cette qualité qu'il a eu
avec le général de Gaulle un entretien
particulier dont rien n'a encore été
[Musique]
révélé c'est en cette qualité enfin que
Lindon Johnson dans son premier discours
au Congrès a défini sa politique en la
plaçant sous le signe de Kennedy en ce
qui concerne les problèmes mondiaux
comme les problèmes nationaux il a
déclaré la mort de John Kennedy exige
que l'œuvre de sa vie se perpétue que
l'Amérique aille de
[Applaudissements]
l'avant
le moment est venu pour les Américains
de toutes les races de toutes les
croyances et de toutes les opinions de
se comprendre et de se respecter
[Applaudissements]
mutuellement mettons donc fin à
l'enseignement de la haine du mal et de
la violence un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
B dans Saint-Pierre de Rome les pè
conciliaires ont terminé leurs travaux
pour cette seconde phase de Vatican I
les deux schémas principaux de la
l'un concernant la liturgie l'autre les
communications sociales ont été voté à
la presque
unanimité c'est alors que Sa Sainteté
Paul 6 a déclaré close la deè session du
concile au cours d'un discours
retentissant où il annonçait qu'il irait
dès janvier faire un pèlerinage en Terre
sainte aucun souverain pontif ne s'est
jamais rendu en Palestine et ce sera la
première fois depuis un siècle et demi
qu'un Pape quittera la péninsule
italienne ce projet demeurer jusqu'ici
absolument secret a eu dans le monde
entier un immense
[Musique]
écho sortant pour une heure de sa
réclusion Jacqueline Kennedy a voulu
malgré son deuil assister à la remise à
Clinton Hill le garde du corps qui tenta
de protéger au péril de sa vie le
président Kennedy au moment de
l'attentat de Dallas de la médaille qui
récompense son héroïsme Clinton Hill
était chargé de la SC de la première
dame des États-Unis depuis l'élection de
son mari à la
[Musique]
présidence dans une vieille maison de la
banlieue parisienne c'est un rendez-vous
de jeunes curieux rendez-vous de blouse
blanche comme en on aujourd'hui en
France des centaines de jeunes gens
saisis par la passion des fusées sous le
vocable ambitieux de club spatial
international des étudiants de jeunes
ingénieurs de simples passionnés se sont
retrouvés aux heures de loisirs pour
ajouter un élément à leur œuvre commune
une fusée qu'ils ont appelé Europe alpha
comme eux un peu partout des jeunes gens
font les mêmes gestes avec le même désir
construire une fusée dont le lancement
un jour témoignera de leur compéten
juvéniles Europe alpha Gérard Venturini
nous l'a décrit le propulseur c'est un
c'est un appareil que nous avons conçu
entièrement il est il est donc
entièrement nouveau et nous n avvons pas
exactement la façon don dont les don les
essais se passeront et c'est pour ça que
cela nécessitera trs certainement un
essais statique
préalablement les essais statiques du
propulseur de leur invention ont eu lieu
avec comme il convenait toutes les
précautions
d'usage minute émouvant s'il en est où
les espoirs de plusieurs mois étent
engagé résultat décevant mais la
déception n'a pas duré mais dites-moi
s'intéresse-on en haut lieu à vos
travaux
et bien écoutez euh pour l'instant nous
ne sommes pas considérés avec beaucoup
de de sérieux étant donné que nos moyens
sont extrêmement limité mais le Centre
national d'études spatial quand même
nous accorde quelques crédits et je
pense que avec son accord par la suite
nous pourrons réaliser certaines choses
dans le domaine spatial évidemment vous
n'avez pas été pressenti par des nations
étrangères non pas encore non merci
rendez-vous donc au jourg et ns je
Brown de banlieu viennent de se
retrouver avec d'autres passionnés sur
le terrain de la courtine Europe alpha
avec sa passagère est maintenant muni
d'un propulseur fourni par le Centre
d'études spatial tous les espoirs sont
permis et après diraon et bien c'est
ainsi que des vocations naissent et
[Musique]
grandissent à une époque où les
sous-marins sont devenus autant de
rampes de lancement possible de fusé la
nécessité s fait sentir de multiplier
les sous-marins chasseurs de sous-marins
c'est à cet objectif que répond le
deuxième submersible atomique
britannique entièrement fabriqué en
Angleterre même le réacteur cette fois
est anglais il pourra rester 2 mois en
plongé comme sa mission de chasse
[Musique]
l'exige aux États-Unis dans le même
temps on a expérimenté l'arme idéal dont
il conviendra de doter de tel bâtiment
ce sont des tubes lanorpis classiques
qu'on utilisera lorsqu'un sous-marin
etemi aura été localisé pour lancer
cette arme nouvelle une fusée de 2
tonnes à tête
nucléaire mais contrairement au torpill
d'hier un moteur propulsera l'engin hors
de l'eau et lorsqu'il se sera détaché la
tête nucléaire poursuivra sa route par
autoguidage vers sa proie
[Musique]
sous-marine
rien ici qui ne soit pas d'Auvergne de
l'enseigne au jambon du chanturg C et
cependant nous sommes à Paris mais Paris
ne peut-il pas compter comme le E
département du Massif central et lesir
de Cab F rêver du pays ils sont 500000
dans l'agglomération parisienne 500000
don le fief le plus connu tourne autour
de la
Bastie le quartier général couvre toute
une partie du 11e arrondissement
[Applaudissements]
un cercle dont le centre serait la place
Voltaire avec en plus deux têtes de pont
situées autour des gares ment au pays la
gare de liyon et la gare deosterlitz
ainsi ils sont plus près de leur clocher
c'est en effet par là qu'ils sont tous
arrivés par là qu'ils repartiront tous
car l'vernia retourne en général mourir
chez lui en génénéral le vernia d'hier
était BIA vin et charbon c'était son
blason qui n' connu ses boutiques sans
éclat aujourd'hui en voie de disparition
puisque de 2500 avant la guerre elles ne
sont plus que la moitié et chaque année
il en disparaît régulièrement une
cinquantaine le Bouat disparaissant
l'Auvergne s'est reconverti on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui elle monopolise à 98 %
les débit de tabac 90 % des cafés et des
restaurants et 50 % des hôtels sont
aussi des fief au vernia ainsi dans tous
les quartiers de Paris et dans tous les
cafés célèbres vous atterrirez
infailliblement à la terrasse d'un
oververnac que ce soit le café de fleur
la coupole le Pavillon Dauphine chez lip
et chez
Dupont et certaines brasseries dites
alsaciennes ont aussi le cœur au
vernia retournons à la galoche où la
cabrette fait rêver tous ses exilés du
pays natal le pays dont ils sont fiers
et dont de temps en temps il compte les
gloires ver
gorix la
faillette
Michel de
l'hôpital bless Pascal esprit de génie
Paul dou qui devint président de la
République Jean Verdier archevêque de
Paris il pens à George Pompidou à
Valérie giscardtin à Jul
romain à Fernand Ren et à qui fait
chanter la jeunesse
d'aujourd'hui c'est une liste
encourageante que sans doute se répète
le jeune auvernia qui débarque avec de
chemises et un complet dans sa petite
valise rassurez-vous ce jeune homme
n'est pas perdu sait où il va car le
Bernier de Paris a son
journal et nul doute que sa petite
annonce trouvera sa destination on le
retrouvera garçon de comptoir chez un de
ses
compatriotes le même journal annoncera
plus tard son mariage avec la fille
d'unvernia et ses premiers succès
commerciaux étape par étape
d'agrandissement en agrandissement le
journal le suivra dans son
[Musique]
ascension
on les retrouvera un peu vieillis sans
doute mais satisfait d'une réussite
qu'ils auront gagné à force de travail
de patience et d'économie plus tard
forun fte il rendra son tablier et
transmettra le flambeau à un compatriote
bien entendu et par l'une des de gares
ils reprendront le chemin du pays en
vagon cette fois maintenant ils vont
vieillir et ils ne penseront plus à
[Musique]
Paris
c'est par le critérium de la première
neige à valdiser qu'a débuté la saison
internationale de ski il s'agit là de
l'une des premières m en train pour les
champions à la veille des Jeux
Olympiques c'est donc pour eu la saison
de vérité qui commence et
particulièrement pour les Français le
meilleur de tous les Français c'est
michelpin qui termine deè de l'épreuve
sous l'il d'un connaisseur
[Applaudissements]
gu le vainqueur le voici c'est
l'Américain
W
par sa victoire il rappelle fort
opportunément à tous les Européens qu'il
pourrait bien jouer les trè Laron aux
Jeux Olympiques
d'inbr B Werner un visage qu'on verra
souvent à l'arrivée des grandes épreuves
ce premier échec des Français à valdiser
n'a pas entamé leur optimisme cette
année ils misent tout sur les Jeux
Olympiques Honor Bonet leur entraîneur
conseil spoulin voici entre autres
JeanClaude k honoré Bonet et
P ils sont tous là et tous PRP l'avenir
en s'entraînant d'arrachepied
l'entraînement d'ailleurs commence au
chalet par le fartage et la vérification
du
matériel et puis chaque jour on prend le
chemin des
[Musique]
pente c'est modui qui ouvre la
piste Jean-Claude Kili lui succède il
est jeune et il a bien du mal à freiner
son tempérament et voilà Kili retiendra
sans doute la
leçon mais le numéro 1 de l'équipe de
France c'est toujours gu Pera c'est sur
lui que se porte une grande partie des
ambitions et des espoirs de l'équipe de
France qui est prête à remporter
d'éclatant succès àbr en tout cas quelqu
soit les résultats d'insbru on ne pourra
pas dire que les français n'auront pas
pris au sérieux les Jeux olympiques
[Musique]
d'hiver à quelques semaines du tournoi
des sa nation l'équipe de France de
rugby a complètement manqué son examen
de passage au Stadium Municipal de
Toulouse devant la Roumanie et ce n'est
pas l'essai de l'élier Gachassin marqué
juste avant la mi-temps qui aura changé
quoi que ce soit à l'opinion qu'on a de
cette équipe de France une équipe
maladroite une équipe sans armes bref
une équipe sans capitaine manœuvrée le
plus souvent par les Roumains qui sont
pourtant pas des foudres de guerre et
l'essai que marque la Roumanie c'est un
cadeau que leur fait l'arrière français
raza
ESS suivi d'un drop 6 à 3 pour les
roues malgré quelques réactions
sporadique et désordonné de l'équipe de
France c'est miracle si la Roumanie n'a
pas marqué d'autres points au cours de
la partie et c'est grâce à leur métier
plus qu'à leur qualité que les Français
arrachent le match nul par un essai de
dupu un essai de très belle facture
d'ailleurs quoi qu'il en soit ce France
Roumanie est une dure déception en tout
cas un sévère avertissement pour les
[Musique]
Français le général de Gaulle accompagné
du ministre de l'information Monsieur
perfit et de Monsieur Bordas directeur
général de la RTF a installé
officiellement la radio dans son palais
sans doute en effet n'y a-t-il pas
d'autres noms pour désigner le plus
grand bâtiment qui est été construit en
France depuis longtemps la dimension
d'une salle comme celle où allit se
dérouler sur trois écrans le spectacle
d'inauguration en Dyon sur cet édifice
sorte de colisé des temps modernes fait
d'aluminium de verre d'acier et de béton
qui a inscrit sa physionomie futuriste
dans le panorama
parisien après la littérature c'est
maintenant le cinéma qui vient de voir
décerner ses prix un jury a attribué au
réalisateur François Leterrier le Grand
Prix du cinéma français un prix créé il
y a 29 ans sous l'égite de Louis lumère
la comédienne Marie du bois elle a reçu
des mains de Pierre Bost le prix Susanne
bianetti décerné par les auteurs de film
per pradiier Roger D et quelques autres
parmi ses devanciers dans cette
distinction éta venu la félicité avec
Simon signor et Noël
[Musique]
Noël l' SP mainant
dans cette aventure des temps modernes
la France n'est pas restée à l'écart
puisque grâce à la station relais de
plemur Bou elle a déjà pu participer par
le moyen des satellites à la première
transmission d'imag en direct de
continent à
continent mais et ce fut la révélation
du Salon du Bourget elle a entrepris
elle-même de conquérir l'espace en
créant ses propres satellites et son
propre lance satellite le véhicule
[Musique]
diamant une fusée gigogne composée d'un
premier étage émeraude d'un second étage
Topaz et d'un 3è étage porteur d'un
satellite la réalisation minutieuse de
ce projet est aujourd'hui assez avancé
pour que nous ayons pu lever le voile
meraude le prier étage est une fusée de
10 m dont les réservoirs peuvent
contenir 13 tonnes de carburant liquide
le moteur tout entier chambre de
combustion et fixé par un système
articulé est
orientable
sur le plus grand banc d'essais statique
d'Europe continentale à Vernon ce
premier étage a déjà subi 200 essais et
dans le bloc souterrain les techniciens
ont pu déjà juger de ces
[Musique]
possibilités pendant 90 secondes la
tuyère développe une poussée continue de
tonnes le moteur du 2e étage Topaz qui
brûlera un bloc de poudre de 2 tonnes
est équipé de quatre tuyères mobiles ce
dispositif permettra l'orientation de
l'étage dans toutes les direction en
fonction des ordres de
pilotage le fonctionnement des tuyères
est ici vérifié dans les conditions
voisines de Cell du
[Musique]
vol pour le 3è étage les études de
résistance des méteaux exposés à la
désagrégation ont conduit à une
conception révolutionnaire une machine
dont la commande électronique
prédétermine le caneva de tissage a été
mise au point pour façonner une
enveloppe en fibre de verre enrobée de
résine
synthétique un spectacle à faire rêver
toutes les fileuses du
[Musique]
monde une telle structure permet à
résister au énormes pressions de
combustion de la poudre aussi bien que
le frais les aciers les plus étudiés
mais avec un poid qu fois
moindre chargé de 650 kg de poudre ce
dernier étage a été lui aussi essayé
avec
[Musique]
succès la transparence des fibres de ver
a permis de suivre à travers le fond du
propulseur la combustion progressive du
bloc de
poud
mais la mise au point des trois étages
n'est pas tout parallèlement il a fallu
soumettre l'ensemble des équipements et
des matériels de mesure monté sur
diamant à ce qu'on nomme les essais
d'ambiance c'est-à-dire aux conditions
particulières que le lancement leur fera
subir échauffement aussi bien que
[Musique]
refroidissement on a ainsi reproduit en
laboratoire dans une série de caissons
les phénomènes qui se produiront pendant
le vol et parmi lesquels les phénomènes
vibratoires et acoustiques ne sont pas
des
[Musique]
moindres la résistance au choc également
a dû être méthodiquement
testé mais aujourd'hui le but n'est plus
loin depuis 1 an Topaz le deuxè étage a
été lancé de nombreuses fois avec succès
et d'ors et déjà ce premier engin
balistique piloté français est en mesure
d'assurer son rôle dans le projet
diamant et dans la région parisienne on
a pu assister au montage des deux
premiers étages émeraudde et Topaz qui
après avoir accompl séparément leurs
essaisont à les accomplir
[Musique]
ensemble et on peut imaginer le lance
satellite diamant tel qu'il apparaîtra
dans sa tour de lancement un jour de
1965 ce jour-là qui n'est plus lointain
il emportera le premier satellite qui
fera participer la France à la ronde
autour de la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Terre c'est le troème barrage qui aura
cédé en 1963 celui de Baldwin Mills à
quelques kilomètres de Los Angeles iss
par miracle la découverte de la brèche à
son début a permis de donner l'alarme à
temps pour permettre l'évacuation sinon
on se demande combien de victimes on
aurait pu compter sous les tonnes d'eau
qui se sont déversé dans la vallée et
qui emportèrent maisons et voitures
comme des coques de
noix 1 million et demi de mè CUB d'eau
potable destinée à l'alimentation de la
région avait disparu par l'énorme
ouverture au-delà de laquelle quelques
heur plus tard on ne devait plus trouver
qu'un spectacle de
[Musique]
désolation toute une vallée enfouie dans
la boue 200 maisons détruites 2000 plus
ou moins réduites à l'état de ruine mais
malgré l'étendue des dégâts matériels on
ne peut s'empêcher de penser qu'un
désastre du genre de celui de langaron a
pu être
évité
à Berlin Noël a fait lever un coin du
voile de tristesse que jette sur la
ville le mur élevé depuis plus de 2 ans
par milliers 60000 personnes par jour
les Berlinois de l'Ouest ont pris
d'assaut 12 bureaux habilités à leur
délivrer des laisser passer pour se
rendre de l'autre
[Musique]
côté pour 400000 hommes femmes et
enfants de tous âg c'était enfin la
possibilité de revoir des êtres chers
que quelques centaines de mètres parfois
ont suffi à depuis 2 ans on a donc
pratiqué quelques brèches dans ce mur
qui isole les deux parties d'une même
ville mais aussi sépare des familles
pour Noël et les fêtes du Nouvel An du
moins ses familles ont pu se retrouver
la trêve pour quelques jours leur a
permis de goûter ensemble comme partout
les joies particulière de ce temps de
rémission à l'Élysée le ministre de la
Santé Publique Monsieur Raymond Marcelin
a présenté au général de Gaulle les
délégués des pays qui ont accepté de
participer à la création d'un organisme
international de lutte contre le cancer
une initiative française on s'en
souvient à laquelle le chef de l'État a
donné son plein
appui pour la première fois depuis 10
ans députés et sénateurs se sont
retrouvés à Versailles le dernier
congrès s'est en effet réuni en 1953
pour l'élection du successeur de
Monsieur Vincent Orial à la présidence
de la République et se termina au bout
de 8 jours par l'élection de René cotti
cette fois la réunion des 757 membres du
Congrès avait un plus mince objectif
celui de modifier les dates des sessions
du Parlement le président de l'Assemblée
monsieur chabandmas a présidé comme le
veut la Constitution cette réunion de
l'Assemblée et du Sénat et la réforme
favorable à un meilleur établissement
des travaux parlementaires a été adoptée
sans difficulté à une confortable
[Musique]
majorité à ceux qui ne verront même pas
les lumières de Noël donnons aujourd'hui
une pensée à ces petits aveugles qu'un
certain frère Louis installa à la
peragotière voici plus de 100 ans à qui
on essaie de faire oublier leur solitude
en les intégrantes au monde des
hommes tu vas lire la lettre
C première
ligne là une centaine d'enfants entre 8
et 14 ans apprennent selon le système
bra à lire et à
écrit en haut à droite en bas à droite
au milieu à
gauche
vasy étrange spectacle d'une classe où
dans un crépitement de pointe crevant le
papier tendu se déroule la plus insolite
des leçons
[Applaudissements]
d'écriture
le fleuve le plus long de France le
toucher a remplacé la vue mais ils
connaîtront comme vous le cours de la
Loire la place des villes le tracé des
frontières et voici peut-être le plus
étrange la leçon de
géométrie une parallèle au
côté
[Applaudissements]
science vivant à ces jeunes êtres privés
de la vue s'ouvre quand même le domaine
de la
connaissancees de Cé gauche et droite et
les vric les cavités plus étroit
l'intérieur tap DEES muscl qui sont
représentés ici mais c'est surout la
musique que pour la plupart il cultive
vers la musique qu'on les guide et si
les notes n'ont pas pour eux la même
forme que pour nous l'univers sensible
de la musique développe les mêmes
enchantements la même ouverture sur le
[Musique]
monde jou la gamme de sol soljeur
peut-être difficile à supporter d'abord
la leçon de violon et sans doute la
vision la plus extraordinaire et le
signe de cette sorte de miracle qu'
[Musique]
avent 3
4 2 3
[Applaudissements]
4 3
[Musique]
4 car c'est le signe qu'ils sont rentrés
dans la vie ces enfants aveugles
auxquels des hommes ont réussi à ouvrir
le monde où nous vivons
[Musique]
elle est venue comme chaque année depuis
bientôt 2000 ans cette fête de Noël que
les peintres depuis Philippo Lippi ont
répété sur d'innombrables toiles cette
histoire merveilleuse de l'Enfant Jésus
né dans les tables réchauffé par le bœuf
et l'âne cette histoire en luminée par
la légende à laquelle chacun mêle ce
qu'il y a de plus pur l'honneur de la
pauvreté la grandeur de la solitude et
l'idée de la paix entre les hommes Noël
c'est aussi le décor que les vieux
peintres flamands ont teinté de
sentiments l'hiver blanc le village dans
son silence autour de l'église dont les
cloches vont sonner c'est encore
l'évocation des réveillons heureux dont
Chardin allume les reflets dans cette
vision de fruits de coquill et de Caraf
ce festin qu'on trouve au centre de la
plus longue nuit de l'année comme au
centre des joies familiales se
réveillant qui est à un soup banal ce
qu'est Noël aux autres
nuits revenons par ces chemins de neige
à la grande leçon de Noël qui est le
miracle de l'enfant car à l'échelle
humaine comme dans le tableau de George
de la tour Noël c'est aussi l'histoire
simple et magnifique de la femme qui met
au monde un enfant l'enfant attendu
révéré fêté même chez les plus humbles
même chez les plus durs l'enfant qui ais
les visages et fait terre les rancœurs
l'enfant qui donne l'espoir d'un monde
plus vrai plus beau plus sage le monde
de
[Musique]
Noël